bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui vous permet de
remettre les pendules à l'heure
vis-à-vis des fake news officielles
bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de la
grèce la grèce s'est elle remise de la
crise
bonjour respect bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches il ya dix ans le 14
janvier 2020 georges papandréou premier
ministre de l'époque annoncé un plan
d'austérité prémices de la crise grecque
aujourd'hui où en est athènes le pays at
il réussi à se redresser quelle place
pour la grèce au sein de l'union
européenne se sont allés questions qui
vont nous occuper aujourd'hui olivier
dans cette émission
alors pour commencer j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un peu de contexte olivier quelles
sont concrètement les origines de la
crise grecque les origines de la crise
grecque c'est l'euro c'est à dire que
vous avez un pays qui n'était absolument
pas capable de suivre les pays de tête
c'est à dire l'allemagne la france à qui
on a imposé une monnaie qui était très
largement surévalué pour elle
qu'ils ont parce qu'il y avait ça lui
permettait d'avoir d'emprunter à des
taux qui était beaucoup plus bas que ce
qu'elle aurait eu si elle avait été tout
seul
qui sont mis à dépenser sans compter et
que le pays s'est retrouvé avec un
endettement qui étaient autour de 160%
cette époque-là du pays du pib avec un
pib qui qui était au ras des pâquerettes
quoi donc
1 vous avez vous avez à ce moment là
quand quand tout se passe bien si vous
voulez quand il n'y a pas de crise
le système tient et le système aurait pu
perdurer si vous voulez s'il n'y avait
pas eu la crise de 2008 la crise de 2008
arrive et à ce moment là on s'aperçoit
que les choses ont été mal faites et mal
monté voulait me dire que si la grèce
n'était pas rentré dans la zone euro y
aurait pas eu de crise grecque en tout
cas elle n'aurait pas été de ceux de ce
niveau là
je pense que alors c'est pas un pays qui
avait une croissance démentiel mais je
pense que le son entrée dans l'euro est
en grande partie responsable de ce qui
lui arrive alors à olivier où en est le
pays exactement aujourd'hui éléments de
réponse avec le tiroir cash d'antoine
passe aujourd'hui dans le tiroir caisse
nous allons vous faire un petit tour
d'horizon de l'économie grecque et qui
de mieux qu'un véritable grec pour vous
en parler
salut à tous et nikos bienvenue dans le
tiroir cache aujourd'hui au programme je
parle de mon merveilleux pays d'origine
je ne parle pas de la dernière les
possessions de kim kardashian
dix ans après la crise la grèce va mieux
en tout cas un peu mieux depuis trois
ans elle a renoué avec la croissance de
1,5 pour cent du pib en 2010 7 à 1,9 en
avec même une prévision de croissance
au-dessus des 2% pour 2025 rôle oble
encore mieux qu'une performance de yoga
qu'elle aie aie aie aie aie à canal la
camorra c'est vous le gouvernement grec
le chômage devrait passer de 17,4 points
en 2019 à 15,6 en 2020 les amis c'est
une belle 5 croyable aussi incroyable
que la baisse des audiences de the voice
c'est essentiellement grâce au tourisme
qui marche plutôt bien
des signes encourageants quant on sait
que le chômage a dépassé et 28% au plus
fort de la crise lire qu'une crise de
nerfs de britney spears ou de mariah
carey
après la dette grecque restent énormes
177 % du pib
quand on sait que la france était morte
de trouille quand lucien a dépassé les
100%
on imagine la sérénité des grecs une
dette qui est détenu majoritairement par
les acteurs institutionnels
comprenez l'union européenne et le fmi
qui ont accepté de repousser le
remboursement jusqu'à 2060 c'est bien
sûr la grèce continue de faire des
efforts vector s'oxyde qui nous sommes
qu'à la grèce reprend enfin des couleurs
et c'est pas pour nous déplaire
on se retrouve très vite donc 50 une
coche bien longtemps leur en 2018 la
grèce enregistré un gain de 9% de
croissance est ce qu'elle est tirée
d'affaires ou alors est-ce que son
économie est encore fragile bien sûr que
non elle est loin d'être tiré d'affaires
tout ça c'est illusoire
c'est à dire que on continue à garantir
des prêts c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
les les banques achètent et que vous
êtes vous vous retrouvez avec des taux
d'intérêt grecs qui sont qui sont passés
en dessous des taux d'intérêt à 10 ans
américain pas si vous rendez compte de
l'aberration
donc tout ça pourquoi parce que on sait
que la banque centrale a de toute façon
européenne
et derrière et soutien souvenez-vous de
la phrase de monsieur draghi whatever it
takes donc il fera tout ce qu'il faut et
je pense que madame lagarde est dans la
même ligne merci olivia les places à la
deuxième partie de cette émission
consacrée à la grèce cette semaine nous
recevons un atelier jenson économiste et
professeur d'économie à nous et ma
bonjour intelligents sont bons jeux mais
aussi à beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bienvenue dans ces caches je
vous posais la même question qu'il ya
olivier selon vous la crise grecque est
elle terminée alors la crise en tant que
phénomène
will est terminée dans la mesure où
l'épisode de crise en lui-même
et voilà il est terminé maintenant est
ce que ça veut dire que la grèce en est
terminé avec ses problèmes ça c'est une
autre question qui prendra beaucoup plus
de temps être résolus on peut simplement
dire que pour le moment
so far so good comme moi aussi donc ça
veut dire qu'effectivement elle a renoué
avec une croissance positive elle a bien
vu son chômage diminuer elle rembourse
comme on lui a demandé enfin ils
remboursent pas mais l'ol fait les
mesures qu'on lui a demandé de mettre en
place et c'est pour ça qu'elle qu'elle
lui permet d'avoir des recettes fiscales
et donc de pouvoir compléter le
programme qui lui a été imposé mais ça
pose la question de son devenir au sein
de l'europe est toujours ouvert dans la
mesure où comme il a été rappelé par
olivier delamarche
en effet la grèce est rentré plus pour
des raisons politiques des raisons
économiques
c'est à dire que si effectivement on
prend le cadre théorique de ce qu'on
appelle les zones monétaires optimales
la grèce n'était pas une bonne candidate
pour y rentrer d'ailleurs souvent les
académiques américain nous le rappelait
grandement en disant que c'était une
hérésie de vouloir faire rentrer un peu
un pays aussi distant
institutionnellement parlant
économiquement parlant de la zone centre
d'euros vous êtes d'accord avec
collision ça veut dire que si
la grèce n'était pas rentré dans la zone
euro l'ampleur de la crise dans laquelle
elle n'aurait pas été la même
en effet puisque là elle a bénéficié de
donc ça a été la réalisation du pire
pour l'allemagne puisqu'il ne voulait
pas de ce qu'on appelle de free riders
de cavaliers le possibilité en fait de
s'endetter sans que ça se voit parce
qu'en fait c'était ça le un des
problèmes de la zone euro
c'est qu'en fait elle donne une garantie
implicite à tous les pays membres
puisque tu es sont plus et lé début de
l'euro donc on n'avait aucune on n'avait
aucunement prévu des scénarios de crise
de défaut de paiement donc tout ça ne
capture pas prévu donc les investisseurs
lorsqu'ils investissent et en europe il
avait tissé en europe
voilà quel que soit le nom précis du
pays malheureusement nous on n'aimait
pas des goûts européens en journée mais
des baisses des bons qui sont des
obligations qui sont libellés dans le
nom de chaque pays et donc effectivement
on a les investisseurs ont bien acheté
des titres grecs mais comme ils
achetaient d'autres titres européens
donc en donnant espèce de garantie leur
plein implicite jusqu'au moment de la
crise et au mans la kryte effectivement
s'est aperçu que bien la grèce ce
n'était pas exactement la même chose que
le reste des pays européens
voilà une réaction on a fait semblant
s'apercevoir parce que franchement c'est
quand même assez évident dès le départ
donc aujourd'hui le jeu direct la seule
manière qu'aurait la grèce pour tirer
une croix sur cette expérience
malheureuse ce serait de sortir de
l'euro or elle pourrait faire une sortie
royale puisque elle ne détient plus sa
dette et que la dette elle est détenue
par les organismes internationaux par la
bce et par différents pays dont
l'allemagne par exemple 1 1 qui en
détient beaucoup et donc que si
aujourd'hui la grèce nous envoyez nous
faire voir gentiment à part l'envahir
il y aurait pas grand chose à faire est
donc on serait obligé de s'asseoir sur
quelques centaines de milliards et la
grèce se porterait très bien parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit quand vous
avez un pays qui fait défaut comme ça et
bien tout le monde se précipite à sa
porte pour lui prêter puisque c'est le
seul pays qui ne sera plus endettée du
tout
on a vu ça avec l'argentine au moment du
défaut de l'argentine où il y avait la
queue à la banque centrale argentine
pour lui prêter de l'argent pour prêter
de l'argent à l'état parce que dès le
lendemain parce que ce pays n'était plus
endettés donc il n'y a pas de problème
en fait vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
sauf que ça fâche ray évidemment
beaucoup madame merkel mais et puis que
ça donnerait peut-être des idées à
d'autres pays pour sortir c'est bien
pour ça qu'on la main tient absolument à
tout prix dans l'europe parce que pour
des raisons politiques
les mêmes qui ont procédé à son entrée
dans l'euro
on n'a pas du tout envie que la grèce
sorte parce que si la grèce sortent ça
pourrait donner des idées aux italiens
ou portugais aux espagnols et j'en passe
et des meilleurs sur la place de la
grèce au sein de l'union donc dans
quelques instants
juste pour vous parler de la grèce la
dette je précise qu elle s'établit à 177
% du pib en 2010 9 et j'aimerais qu'on
vienne sur les indicateurs
justement la croissance la grèce ça vise
une croissance de 2,8 pour cent en 2020
est-ce que la situation aujourd'hui la
grèce est moins bonne ou meilleure que
qu'elle ne l'était en 2010 voilà en ce
moment elle est les meilleurs
elle a des voiles à des indicateurs qui
sont en tout cas les réformes qui blocs
qui faisait obstacle à ce que l'activité
économique reparte et on en a un petit
peu moins il est certain qu'en fait le
problème de la grecque et surtout comme
je disais initialement c'est surtout les
problèmes institutionnels series ont une
façon d'organiser leur économie en fait
qui relativement encore fermées par
rapport est pas et pas très innovant par
rapport au reste des économies
européennes
donc c'est un système a ses bureaux très
bureaucratique et c'est pour ça que
l'ensemble des mesures c'était d'essayer
de simplifier en fait l'administration
exactement c'est évidemment ces réformes
structurelles prennent du temps
alors les les fruits vont pas se voir
immédiatement et d'ailleurs il ya des il
ya des dissonances cognitives au sein
même de la grèce puisque d'un côté on
veut par exemple les programmes de
privatisation on les a lancé il y en a
déjà eu des le port du pirée qu'a été
achetés on avait l'ancien aéroport
d'athènes qui a été hachée mais en fait
il ne se passe rien parce qu'en fait
ceux qui ont acheté pour pouvoir
transformer bâtir par des centres
commerciaux fayyad et plusieurs projets
là dessus en fait sont en fait
aujourd'hui les projets ne nous donnait
lieu à pas grand chose puisqu'ils sont
arrêtés par des parts des probables des
obstacles administratifs et aussi des
obstacles liés à des problèmes
archéologiques en tout cas c'est comme
ça que les obstacles sont les plus
évidents et donc en fait pour le moment
il se passe rien donc ça veut dire qu'en
fait c'est au delà
quand on dit bon et les privatisations
ça peut transformer en fait le problème
donc c'est que si vous allez
privatisation mais qu' il ya une
bureaucratie derrière qui les empêchent
la réalisation
eh bien il n'y a pas grand chose qui va
se faire derrière ça veut dire
concrètement que les réformes
structurelles qu'on a imposé à la grèce
n'était pas de toute façon il faut que
ce soit le problème c'est que donne on a
un peu l'impression dans ce problème
grec que c'est on veut en fait forcé la
marge du transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du pays dans un peu un
pays plus voilà plus ouvert plus
libérale plus de marché et puis
peut-être qu'une partie
et sans aucun doute une grande partie
n'ont pas envie de cette transformation
notamment des aussi des politiciens qui
sont en place depuis longtemps
à certains égards ça fait ça arrive ça
fait résonance en fête avec mes amis
avec l'italie notamment l'italie du sud
où on voit bien on a les mêmes peu près
les mêmes mots avec une lenteur une
bureaucratie avec beaucoup d'obstacles
avec avec en fait donc des obstacles qui
empêchent l'activité économique de ceux
de se réaliser
en tout cas d'avoir des perspectives
plutôt dynamique avec quand on n'est pas
content les personnes en fait
s'aperçoivent qu'elles peuvent rien
d'intérieur en fait partie et ici en
fait le plus grand mal dont souffre la
grèce aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait elle
a vu beaucoup de ces jeunes s'en aller
et ça effectivement c'est un mauvais
indicateur puisque ça veut dire
qu'effectivement comme on voit que de
l'intérieur on peut rien faire ils vont
samba l'extérieur si on s'en bat à
l'extérieur ceux qui sont qui reste en
fait sont ceux qui ont le moins intérêt
à ce que le pays trop se transforme donc
voilà donc à tort ou à raison encore une
fois c'est des choix et des choix de
population mais en effet pour que ces
réformes puissent aboutir serre si on
veut vraiment aller vers une graisse
plus plus libérale dont plus de marché
il faut qu'elle se transforme
hélas la transformation elle est quand
même pas non plus encore aboutie du tout
elle est juste en cours vous êtes
d'accord normal de la grèce c'est cette
fuite des cerveaux alors ce sens étant
et ça d'ailleurs ça explique votre
chiffre du chômage
c'est simplement c'est pas qu'ils le
chômage a baissé c'est que les gens sont
partis
on retrouve d'ailleurs le même phénomène
en espagne le même phénomène au portugal
et sert donc à chaque fois on se
félicite de cette baisse du chômage mais
c'est une baisse du chômage en qui est
une fausse baisse du chômage sur le en
fait rien n'a été réglé je vous rappelle
quand même que au moment de la de la
crise en 2011 de mémoire je crois que le
l'endettement de la grèce était de 162 %
mais rompu mais aujourd'hui on est à 180
donc j'ai pas vu les choses
s'amélioraient et
et le la croissance une fois qu'on a
baissé son pib de plus de 25 % s'il
voulait avoir une croissance de 8%
on se trouve pas par terre non plus donc
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes les mêmes conditions qui ont qui
ont provoqué cette crise c'est à dire un
euro qui n'est pas adaptée à la grèce
donc vous aurez le même système là
aujourd'hui pourquoi ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure
pourquoi les taux grecs sont en dessous
des taux américains ce qui est quand
même un truc un peu aberrant enfin on
sent qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
qui va pas à entre la grèce et les états
unis c'est quand même pas les mêmes
économies microsoft s'est pas grecque et
et amazon s'est pas grecs n'ont plus que
je sache
et donc on a on à cette aberration qui
est maintenue par la bce est pourquoi
elle est maintenue par la bce pour des
raisons politiques parce que ils savent
très bien que si jamais la grèce
complètement étrangler sortait de deux
euros ça provoquerait probablement la
fin de l'euro en plus sur ce que madame
disait à propos de l'investissement de
des privatisations plus tôt
ça ressemble plus à un pillage pour moi
qu'une privatisation c'est à dire que je
rappelle quand même que le port du pirée
maintenant il est chinois que les
aéroports ont été achetés par les
allemands si mes souvenirs sont bons en
tout cas un imprimé en plus donc ça veut
dire que l'argent il par là bas il est
restreint
on va juste marqué une courte pause
bienvenue dans ces cas chez vous nous
rejoignez on parle de la grèce cette
semaine avec un attali jenson
économistes elle n'était ni juste avant
que je coupe olivier
nous vous raconter que le pire les
privatisations pour lui pour lui
ressembler plus à du pillage
c'est votre avis aussi non c'est pas mon
avis mais de toute façon c'est bien
évidemment puisque caen lors du de la
pour ces privatisations par exemple vous
allez avoir du développement
d'infrastructures et puis de commerce
est donc là il y aura bien une activité
générée sauf territoire bon maintenant
effectuer les capitaux sont étrangers
mais je dirais que ça c'est pas si
surprenant que ça puisque d'état sont
les les grecs fayard il ya certainement
peu grecque qui pouvaient s'offrir la
privatisation alors que ça peut
intéresser des investisseurs étrangers
donc du point de vue de ce qui s'est
passé en grèce est pas très surprenant
que ce soit des investisseurs étrangers
qu'ils soient positionnés maintenant
c'est sage et sa balle quand même généré
une activité sur place alors bon pour le
cas des chinois faut être plus réservé
puisque souvent les chinois viennent
avec leurs armes et chinois pour
travailler sur place après les com et
les commerces qui seront verts seront
peut-être pas forcément de commerce
chinois donc il y aura quand même une
activité qui sera généré localement mais
oui de toute façon le problème de la
grèce comme tout tous les problèmes de
ces pays qui sont en tout cas qui ne
sont pas clairement des pays
franchement en économie ouverte et
libérale c'est que vous avez un décalage
va en tout cas dans lequel l'euro c'est
clair qu'il ya un fort décalage et leur
sortie éventuelle de l'euro pourquoi pas
mais je moi je répondrai pourquoi faire
c'est à dire effectivement pourquoi pas
il aurait effectivement au moins ils
auraient plus la contrainte de la
monnaie mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont en
faire de cette monnaie plus faible
puisque de toute façon ce sont des pays
avant l'euro qui étaient des pays
chaotique au niveau de la stabilité
monétaire
hélas l'instabilité monétaire ne génère
pas non plus de grande croissance on
voit bien pour l'argentine qui n'arrête
pas de faire du yo yo et est en fait un
entretien de la pauvreté en fin de la
croissance économique qui ne repart
jamais qui repart et puis retombe donc
voilà donc c'est pour ça que la
situation de la gac elle est
problématique
alors peut-être que il serait plus il
serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
voilà pour au moins on pourrait pas dire
que c'est la faute de l'europe ça au
moins ça sera clair mais
reprendre sa monnaie ne résout pas tous
les toutous les problèmes on est tout à
fait d'accord ça ne résout pas les
problèmes si vous gardez les mêmes
équipes en place
je pense qu'à ainsi prace même avec la
drague ça ne fonctionnerait pas mais
bien sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes
qui dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro et
en récupérant sa manette ça on est tout
à fait d'accord là dessus mais on ne
peut rien résoudre non plus en gardant
la même structure qui a amené la grèce
là où elle est c'est à dire que on a
toujours une dette qui va continuer à
augmenter parce que ils vont être en
déficit budgétaire permanent parce qu'il
va bien falloir à un moment la
croissance elle va pas revenir comme ça
d'un coup même si il ya deux commerces
qui ne sont pas chinois dans le port du
pirée ça va pas changer la face du monde
et donc c'est un pays qui
structurellement ne va pas avoir des
croissances de 4 ou 5 % sur tout comme
on l'a dit les jeunes se sont barrés et
que c'est un pays qui maintenant en
termes de de natalité et de démographie
jaillit et donc vous aurez une espèce de
déflation rampante en grèce une
croissance qui va être très très faible
et qui en tout cas ne couvrira jamais le
le coût de la dette
donc aujourd'hui même si vous êtes en
dessous de 2 des états unis vous êtes
quand même
de mémoire 1 40 autour d'eux sur le sur
le 10 ans grec 1,42 façon tout à fait
artificielle c'est la bce qui fixe le
prix là c'est pas un prix marché donc
c'est la bce qui fixe le prix vous êtes
1 40 à 1 40 x 180 %
ça fait de toute façon plus que la
croissance s'est terminée juste pour
terminer et quelles perspectives
d'avenir concrètement pour la grèce et
bien qu une intéressante question mais
c'est une question effectivement qui est
en jeu
je regarde aussi beaucoup l'italie et
pour moi c'est à peu près les mêmes
questions fins et la grèce ressemble à
l'italie du sud
et c'est exactement même question on se
demande comment on peut sortir de cette
impasse parce que ils ont la même
caractéristique ou là est rappelé aux
populations vieillissantes
donc de toute façon on sait bien que la
grèce avait lé problème empire similaire
au nôtre c'est à dire au niveau des
retraites puisque la part du pib
consacrée aux retraites est élevé donc
il va pas diminuer puisque on est en
train de dire que le pays vieillit donc
effectivement s'il n'y a pas de ressort
d'activité parce que le problème de ce
qu'il faut dans les deux sens
alors elle est là l'italie du nord se
dire que là elle a quand même une partie
qui tire mais pareil est-ce qu'elle va
tirer toujours et on peut toujours se
poser question mais vous voyez l'italie
ça va faire je crois plus de ça fait
trente ont presque trente ans qu'elle
est qu'elle est à plus de 100% de
de dette au niveau du pib donc en soi le
100 % ou 260 est pas un problème
le problème c'est de savoir si on peut
il se passer exactement
et si effectivement on a toujours des
investisseurs qui investissent puisque
même si on prend encore pire le cas du
japon qui est à plus de 200 et lui il
n'y a aucun problème de financement
puisque ce sont les japonais qui
financent eux-mêmes parce qu'ils ont une
forte épargne réf donc voilà donc si on
n'a pas cette espèce de deux ressorts
vertueux en tout cas de faire en sorte
que ça se passe pas trop mal mais enfin
bon le japon n'est pas un modèle non
plus ils financent peut-être leur dette
mais leur croissance est très mal parce
que c'est aussi un pays vieillissant
donc on s'aperçoit bien que ce ne sont
pas des pays qui ont des modèles en fait
porter économique et cdc des pays qui
doivent effectivement réfléchir sur sur
leur modèle économique et social
merci beaucoup un athée diversia voie
d'être venu sur le plateau de ces cas je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
professeur d'économie à nos emma c'est
l'heure du chiffre de la semaine olivier
0 5% c'est le nouveau taux du livret a à
partir du 1er février la rémunération de
ce placement n'avait pas bougé depuis
2015 s'établissant à 0 75%
olivier concrètement comment est-ce
qu'on calcule cbs comment est calculée
l'état décide s'ils sont dans un
environnement aujourd'hui dans toute
l'europe est dans une bonne partie du
monde de taux zéro voire de taux
négatifs
donc si vous voulez avoir un produit
d'épargné avec un un taux fixe annoncé à
l'as vence
et qui ne qui est positif devient de
plus en plus difficile donc qu'est-ce
que vous faites ça veut dire simplement
que dans le livre est à vous allez être
obligé de mettre de plus en plus
d'actions je rappelle que d'en livrer à
vous avez des obligations souvent d'état
et puis vous avez une pas une poche
actions et donc vous allez pour
augmenter la lafa pour garantir cette
rémunération
quand vous avez devant vous que des taux
qui sont négatives c'est compliqué de
faire du 0,75 ou même du 05 donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que petit à petit
ils vont être obligés de dégrader très
probablement les obliques qui mettent
dans leur livret a pour pouvoir amener
un petit peu plus de rémunération ce qui
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
alors je je je constate que c'est le
produit préféré des français par et il
est bien il ferait bien de revoir leurs
préférences solution j'en suis là je
sais pas s'il s'avoue ravi d'avoir dû 0
5% sur un truc qui va être obligé de
prendre de plus en plus de risques pour
délivrer ses 0 5% en forme après si vous
amuse
oui mais moi je trouve ça juste ridicule
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
prochain numéro est la semaine prochaine
en attendant vous pouvez visionner les
précédentes émissions sur notre site
internet arte france pour un tv un
dernier mot olivier écouter
je pense que la grèce malheureusement
n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de choix soit
le sort de l'euro et à ce moment là
en effet avec une autre équipe elle
pourra recommencer sur bonnes bases
soit elle reste est à ce moment là ça
sera une longue agonie